[Applaudissements]
partager dans un instant est juste on
lui a posé des questions gênantes vous
avez deux solutions deux solutions soit
ils répondre soit la partager avec une
autre personne autour de la table qui
sera obligé d'y répondre à votre place m
et j'adore ce dos à sa j'adore
alors lycées quand la dernière fois que
vous vous êtes fait arrêter par la
police alors parler ouais c'était à
saint-etienne j'ai envoyé un texto
jetant banon j'étais perdu je jouais à
saint-etienne j'étais perdu je cherchais
ma route je me suis fait arrêter par un
flic
j'ai essayé de jouer sur le côté je
viens jouer dans votre ville soyez sympa
et c'est ce qui m'a enlevé trois points
ça se bagarre et on a dix ans leur bref
on embrasse la maréchaussée d'accord moi
je non moi non et en fait le mec il a
essayé de faire une petite blague fait
écouter ici c'est pas l'office du
tourisme y voit là et il m'a laissé avec
mes trois points en moins
donc ça j'aurais peut-être dû à partager
cela ne s'est pas assez drôle c'est
archi jean jésus perdu mais voilà on le
sait la vérité c'est too much et orange
et invente un truc non quand j'ai tué
quelqu'un est le cas les pour vous
l'animateur télé chez qui vous embêter
le plus occupé de chavannes
[Rires]
et ce n'est sans parce que il m'a envoyé
un texto était aussi là combien de
versailles a séduit réponse est en fait
comme ça parce que c'était vrai nom
c'était une blague
alors donc je peux vous prévoyez
laquelle donc le plus ringard
celui que je sais pas je vais prendre le
plus méchant tiens-toi gilles verlant
mais avec toi méchant si c'était pas
méchant mais pour toi le plus ringard ou
le plus ringard j'irai pas dans motus
n'y a pas invité alors qu'à moi tu sais
pas le jeu dont tous dérivés le
l'animateur voilà bon je suis pas
d'accord
j'adore qui arrivé car aucun endroit
génial il est super 15 avait pris la
mauvaise personne pour partager ici on
vous propose de l'argent pour animer une
soirée en boîte de nuit vous dit oui à
partir de combien oui la donne à
quelqu'un c'est l'art c'est la dernière
fois que j'ai animé c'était dans une
partouze
j'étais payé quatre filles d'accord vous
voulez lapandry j ouer jaune la partager
avec toi jean michel berrit choisi vous
c'est quoi animer une soirée en boîte de
nuit à peine deux mois début de semaine
on a vu qu'ils y seraient à 5 euros
alors non je sais pas parce qu'il faut
compter le déplacement jeu des 1000
milles euros d'accord pour la soirée des
prix
ouais et que maintenant les mecs qu'ils
ont payé 5000 francs et dit qu'elle est
l'endroit le plus insolite vous avez
fait l'amour dans matthieu delormeau
renault
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un qui rentre dans ta petite
maison blanche
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première dame est lisse il y
avait un incendie et que vous pouviez
chauve et toutes les personnes autour de
cette table sauf une hausse et méchant
ce serait laquelle
oui mais ça peut arriver hier à partir
vous pouvez la dollée fois la donne à
quelqu'un mais je veux la fourguette
ouais super et dont je ne me sens pas
moi même non non non je suis sympa dont
alors alors non alors eh bien je ne
souffre pas
je vis cette phrase la syrie parce que
c'est quand même c'est pas il nous
manquera pas échappé
vous faut resserrer pour moi et mon
frère y mangera pas sinon je sauve pas
ce que met la cellule
merci tient et thierry bah voilà
inquiétez pas rester chez moi l'année
prochaine décidément être sympa alors
est dit racontez-nous votre dernier
atout dernière à tokyo on raconte
dernière à thonon c'était y'a states
j'étais dans un restaurant j'ai écrit un
petit mot à une fiv la trouve jolie
jeudi aux serveurs de la de le donner
enfin je pars du restaurant ce que je
suis un peu timide et je crois qu'il l'a
donné à une mauvaise personne c'est pas
sûr peut appeler ça un râteau mais de
quelqu'un s'était pas elle ri cha il a
pris des rats torito pareil vous avez
quel âge l'état 25 à 25